From creepy new hidden details in Gilbert's
Magic Shop, to Mary's shifting lip droop,
and secret Max, Dani, and Ursula references!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and I've
re-watched and paused Hocus Pocus 2 all over
again, to hunt down another stack of easter
eggs and details you might have missed in
the movie!
Mary's crooked jaw is part of her iconic look;
however, our awesome eagle-eyed movie lovers
spotted that in the sequel her lip droop has
shifted to the opposite side of her face compared
to the original movie.
Initially, Mary's crooked lip is on the same
side of her mouth as in the first film, keeping
continuity between the two movies.
However, when Winnie slaps her in the face,
the droop slips to the other side where it
remains for the rest of the film.
Kathy Najimy revealed she had to make this
change as, after 30 years, it's too difficult
for her to maintain the lip droop on the original
side.
I do love the clever little way the filmmakers
integrated this change naturally into the
sequel.
Now, when the camera cuts to a giant poster
for Mayor Traske's re-election campaign, you'll
have to pause the movie and look really closely
at the buildings in the background.
Just over his shoulder and behind Cassie is
a house that will be familiar to hard-core
Hocus Pocus fans.
Yes, it's Max and Dani's family home from
the original movie!
And talking of Dani, the Witch Mother's red
outfit in the sequel is a homage to the red
witch costume that Dani wore for Halloween
back in the 90s.
In the sequel, it's the Witch Mother who gifts
Book to Winnie, potentially contradicting
what was established about the spellbook in
the original film.
This is the spell book of Winifred Sanderson.
It was given to her by the devil himself.
And, tons of our movie lovers have been asking
about this, so let me clarify why this probably
isn't an error or a plot hole.
It's very likely that Allison's explanation
is simply based on unverified stories and
myths that the people of Salem had heard about
the Sanderson Sisters over the years and assumed
they must have been in league with the devil.
Perhaps because thou eateth the children?
In fact, given that in the sequel, Billy Butcherson
goes out of his way to say that the stories
about his and Winnie's relationship are untrue,
we could also argue that other legends about
the Sandersons might be incorrect too.
There is, however, a tribute to that original
devil story on the replica black flame candles
Gilbert sells in his shop.
You can see this devil-like figure here giving
a book to some characters wearing pointy,
witchy hats.
The candles are also white and decorated in
red, similar to the black flame candle that
Max lit in the first movie.
And I found even more little tributes to the
first film in Gilbert's shop.
Pause as the Sanderson Sisters make their
dramatic return to their old cottage and by
the door you'll see two small wooden cages
which appear to be smaller reproductions of
the ones where the witches imprisoned the
bullies Jay and Ice.
Let us out of here.
We're really sorry.
By the way, if you're wondering what happened
to the pair after they were left hanging in
the witches' house, well, there's a horrifying
theory that when young Gilbert found them
there in 1993, he turned them into his two
new black flame candles.
And I've got a video on that which I'll link
to at the end of this video.
Another hidden easter egg in the store is
this book and its cover design, which is actually
the poster for Bette Midler's special event
"In Search of the Sanderson Sisters".
There's also a sneaky cameo during Gilbert's
presentation about the legendary three witches.
This woman dressed as a pirate is Jen D'Angelo
who wrote the screenplay for Hocus Pocus 2.
She's playing the part of Liam's mum, the
kid who kept asking questions about the sisters
and then asked this rather awkward one…
What's a virgin?
Uh, that is a...
person who has never...
lit a candle.
That's also a reference to the original movie's
somewhat weird obsession with Max's virginity.
Are you a virgin?
Look, I'll get it tattooed on my forehead,
okay?
When Gilbert opens up Book after hearing the
news that the Sanderson Sisters have returned,
it sends a powerful ray of light through the
magic shop's roof, similar to the burst of
light it gave off in the original movie after
Max and Allison opened it, and which led the
witches to the spell book's location.
In my first paused video for Hocus Pocus 2,
I mentioned how Winnie's belt buckle was identical
to the Witch Mother's brooch around her neck.
And as many of our marvellous movie lovers
have also pointed out, the three new girls
all wear the same type of necklace, in a tribute
to each of the Sanderson Sister's outfits.
So, each necklace has three coloured stones,
a green one, a reddish-purple one, and a brownish-red
one;
green is for Winnie, red is for Sarah and
brown is for Mary.
Each necklace also has several five-pointed
stars, similar to the star in Winnie and the
Witch Mother's brooches.
And the moon symbols in each necklace can
be spotted scattered around various embroidered
designs on Winnie's costume.
On top of that, the young girls' clothes are
also a nod to the older witches and their
outfits;
Becca has a green jacket that matches her
with Winnie;
Izzy has a beige-brown cardigan that corresponds
to Mary;
and Cassie's pink jacket relates to Sarah.
Actress Lilia Buckingham has also said that
Cassie's cardigan is a deliberate call-back
to Allison's cardigan, hinting at a potential
connection between the two characters.
Plus her tie-dye shirt is a shout-out to Max's
tie-dye top in the original movie.
Belissa Escobedo has also said her burgundy
cardigan is a tribute to Allison's red hooded
outfit in the first movie.
I also noticed another subtle connection between
the new witches and the Sanderson Sisters.
When Becca and Izzy cycle through Salem's
historic district to go into the woods, they
cycle down the same street and go past the
same original buildings that the young witch
sisters originally ran through when they fled
Salem to go into the Forbidden Forest in 1653.
I mentioned in my previous video a bunch of
easter eggs and details hidden at the Salem
Scare Fest, but I spotted a new one on my
rewatch.
When Becca and Izzy meet Major Traske for
the first time, just behind them is a woman
dressed as a witch.
She's tied to a stake and getting photographed
by someone in a Puritan costume.
This is a little nod to a myth that witches
were burned during the Salem witch trials,
rather than hanged as was actually the case
and as we saw happen to Winnie, Mary and Sarah
in the first movie.
When the Sanderson Sisters stumble across
the pun-tastically named Apple-Plectic stall,
they're delighted to discover what they believe
to be a man being drowned.
And appropriately enough, below the stall's
name is the phrase "Rotten To The Core", a
Disney easter egg and reference to the 2015
Descendants film which was directed by Kenny
Ortega, who also directed the original Hocus
Pocus movie.
Another interesting little detail here is
that Descendants introduced a new generation
of characters who were the children of famous
Disney villains, and in Hocus Pocus 2 we're
introduced to a new trio of young witches
who by the end take on the legacy of the infamous
Sanderson Sisters.
When the wicked sisters sing and enchant the
audience at the festival in Hocus Pocus 2,
among the crowd are three ladies dressed as
The Supremes, a little hat-tip to the three
Supremes who were also bewitched in the original
movie.
As another of our awesome movie lovers, Disney
Gal, told us there's also someone dressed
as Ursula from Disney's The Little Mermaid
here with the villain's iconic spiky white
hair, crown, and nautilus necklace.
Also among the dancing crowd is a guy who
has a look about him that reminds me of the
Reverend Traske from Salem's early days.
Another of our marvellous movie lovers, Cora,
says this guy here is wearing a Halloween
costume of zombie Billy Butcherson.
By the way, several more of our movie lovers
have said that Billy's stitches look like
the word 'Kill', but I think it might actually
be 'Kiss', a reference to the single kiss
that Billy says he only ever had with Winnie.
I shared one kiss with Winifred.
She has sullied my name for eternity.
There's a funny call-back to the first movie
when Winnie and Mary encounter a talking virtual
assistant inside the Traske home...
ALEXA: Sorry, I didn't quite catch that.
Who said that?
Winnie...
There is a small woman trapped in that box.
This is a hat tip to the how the sisters were
tricked by technology in the first movie when
Max, Allison and Dani trapped them by using
a cassette machine playing back a French language
lesson.
Bonjour!
Je veux mon livre.
After Becca traps the Sandersons inside a
salt circle, Winnie tests the force field
by pushing Sarah into the invisible barrier,
similar to how she pushed her onto the road
outside their cottage to check if it was safe
or not.
'Tis a black river.
And when Traske arrives back to find the witches
locked in his garage, as his car's headlights
illuminate the space, Winnie and her sisters
panic thinking the sunrise has come for them.
The sun.
Oh, no.
I don't wanna die.
This moment is a fun nod to how Max and Allison
tricked the Sandersons in a similar way in
the first film when they were rescuing Dani
and Binx.
The sun!
It hurts.
And there's even more intriguing details and
connections in the sequel such as how Winifred's
eyes glow purple as she casts the Magicae
Maxima spell, similar to the Witch Mother's
eyes when she uses her powers.
I talk a lot more about that plus whether
Cobweb is actually a human who young Winnie
turned into a cat in my Hocus Pocus 2 theories
video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
Let me know what your favourite moment was
in Hocus Pocus 2 and if you spotted any other
details.
And if you enjoyed this video, do leave a
thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying this movie with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!